[Music]
yet another star of buffy the vampire
slayer has spoken out about the show's
big boss
david boreanaz who played angel both on
joss whedon's original buffy show and
his popular spin-off angel has released
a statement regarding allegations of
abusive behavior on the set of buffy
after his co-star charisma carpenter who
played cordelia alleged that whedon
hazed and bullied her during and after
her pregnancy
boreanaz took to twitter to voice his
support for carpenter responding to
carpenter's original post on twitter
boreana said
i am here for you to listen and support
you proud of your strength
clearly the two had been communicating
offline prior to that message
carpenter responded i know you're there
for me david i appreciate all you've
done to demonstrate that support
privately as well
especially since wednesday thank you so
much what do you want the same thing you
do
several of carpenter's buffy co-stars
have spoken out as well whether they're
backing up her claims or simply offering
support
buffy summers herself sarah michelle
geller simply wrote
while i'm proud to have my name
associated with buffy summers i don't
want to be forever associated with the
name josh sweden
i'm more focused on raising my family
and surviving a pandemic currently so i
will not be making any further
statements at this time
but i stand with all survivors of abuse
and i'm proud of them for speaking out
meanwhile james marsters who played
spike tweeted while i will always be
honored to have played the character of
spike
the buffy set was not without challenges
i do not support
abuse of any kind and am heartbroken to
learn of the experiences of some of the
cast
i send my love and support to all
involved on february 10th carpenter
joined forces with former whedon
colleague greg fischer who accused the
director of inappropriate behavior on
the set of justice league
and posted a lengthy accusation against
the director on social media
alongside the hashtag i stand with ray
fisher charisma wrote in her
statement for nearly two decades i have
held my tongue and even made excuses for
certain events that traumatized me to
this day
joss whedon abused his power on numerous
occasions while working together on the
sets of buffy the vampire slayer and
angel
the disturbing incidents triggered a
chronic physical condition from which i
still suffer
it is with a beating heavy heart that
isaiah cooked in isolation and at times
destructively
carpenter detailed several disturbing
incidents with wheaton many of which
were centered around her pregnancy
bringing up several examples joss has a
history of being casually cruel
he has created hostile and toxic work
environments on set since his early
career
i know because i experienced it
firsthand repeatedly
examples carpenter alleged included
frequent threats to fire her and mocking
her body
weight including calling her fat when
she was four months pregnant and weighed
126 pounds
she also accused him of fostering a
generally hostile work environment
saying he was mean and biting
disparaging about others openly and
often played favorites pitting people
against one another to compete and buy
for his attention and approval
carpenter also claimed that whedon
bullied her about her religious beliefs
and her pregnancy
forced her to work late and extensive
hours late into her pregnancy and fired
her from the series after she gave
birth she concluded it is abundantly
evident that joss has persisted in his
harmful actions continuing to create
wreckage in his wake
my hope now by finally coming forward
about these experiences
is to create space for the healing of
others who i know have experienced
similar serialized abuses of power
michelle trachtenberg who portrayed dawn
summers provided her own claims
saying that she was now brave enough as
a 35 year old woman to publicly accuse
whedon of inappropriate behavior
she wrote on instagram so now people
know what joss did the last comment i
will make on this was there was a rule
saying he's not allowed in a room alone
with michelle again
joss whedon did not immediately respond
to the allegations
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the latest hot topics are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one